well moving on to this Falls officially
here although we are saying it might not
feel like it just yet it's beautiful
Beauty and lifestyle advisor Don
McCarthy is sharing some of her top fall
finds and they're under 50 for everyone
in the family hello Las Vegas now first
up for the fall I have something for the
fur kids in the family and being a fur
mom I care about what I give my dog but
have you ever noticed when you give your
dog a new treat you always smell it
first I admit I do when they set out to
create the crown detail line they knew
the treats had to be so tasty they would
not only have the pup Sterling but their
parents too using only the highest
quality natural and organic ingredients
because we want the best for our pets
you won't find any preservatives in
these tasty snacks once you smell them
you're definitely going to want to even
try them for yourself and yes I did try
a bite the jack-o-lantern pumpkin spice
flavor are part of their limited edition
flavors made in small batches and can be
purchased just on their website at
crowntotail.com they sell out real quick
so get them before they're gone and make
sure your dog has a treat this Halloween
season
now for some fall Beauty and I have
something that is a game changer blue
lean this patented anti-aging Miracle
Worker methylene blue was developed by a
scientist that studies the aging process
this product promotes skin cell Health
repairs and reverses skin aging and
protects against UVA and UVB radiation
methylene blue doubles your body's own
collagen and elastin it's smoothing
hydrating and firms the skin it's the
first real retinol alternative and it
outperforms retinol with zero irritation
and no sun Sensitivity I love the body
fix which is great for my hands neck and
decollete and if you're looking to see a
difference in your skin try the night
and daily eye cream visit blueline.com
next I have something for the kids
butterfly love from above by Melissa
Stewart it's in a heartwarming story of
one little girl's journey through grief
after losing her best friend a butterfly
named twinkle star feels that her
happiness is gone forever but the love
and joy from her Pony Luna which I can
relate to as I had a pony growing up
shows her that there is something
beautiful to see when we take a moment
to always just look up readers will see
the happiness and healing power that
animals can bring to our lives go to
Melissa stewartauthor.com to find out
more
and lastly I recently came across
Scentsy Bond and am obsessed and know
you will be too these luxury laundry
detergent sheets and dryer sheets are
infused with high-end fragrances and
will make your sheets towels and clothes
smell amazing this fall they are Ultra
concentrated eco-friendly and free of
any harsh chemicals the detergent sheets
melt in hot and cold water are
liquidless lightweight and compact
making them perfect for travel the dryer
sheets reduce static and wrinkles and
are great for the gym bags drawers
suitcases Etc they are biodegradable
eco-friendly and sustainable they're a
great gift to give as well as we head
into the holiday season and all you have
to do is go to scentsybonne inc.com so
happy fall and if you want more
information on any of these products I
featured just go to dawnscorner.com